this is the moment they were dreaming of
nazanin zagari ratcliffe and anusha
ashori both held for years in iran
walking off the plane and onto british
soil again finally they are home and
they are safe
at raf bryce norton where they landed an
emotional reunion with their families
with her husband richard and cradling
her daughter gabriella do i smell nice i
haven't having
anything
together again and this time for good
i've met the families
they're safe and well
people are very very good spirits i
think it's been a really difficult 48
hours the expectation
that they would be
released but we weren't sure and right
until the last minute so it's been it's
been very emotional but also a really
happy moment for the families
it was at exactly eight minutes past one
this morning that the plane carrying
nazanin zagari ratcliffe and anusha
ashori touched down here at raf bryce
norton they spent an hour inside with
their families behind closed doors
talking and hugging before leaving to
spend the night in government
accommodation it was a journey that
finally gave them their freedom from an
unimaginable ordeal
nightmare began in 2016 when she was
detained by iranian security services as
she tried to leave the airport in tehran
after a holiday
their hidden cameras capturing her shock
accused of spying against the iranian
regime she was held for years on charges
she always denied and subjected to what
her husband richard said amounted to
torture
it was his years of relentless
campaigning that helped to secure her
release including a hunger strike
outside the foreign office
persistence that finally paid off as
joyous photos emerged of nazanin and
anusha grinning on the plane that was to
bring them home their relief palpable
now the nightmare is over they can
finally look forward to life with their
families together again
casey barnfield sky news